salut c'est le sucre grosse actu au tour
de samsung on a parlé il ya quelques
jours du samsung galaxy s 10 on a
également parlé du galaxy note 9
on a aussi parlé du galaxy s il ya pas
mal d'actu au tour de samsung sortent
beaucoup de produits à des produits très
important et majeurs qui vont sortir à
l'année prochaine
et là c'est au tour parler de la gamme
samsung galaxy a qui va sortir l'année
prochaine et qui va franchement mais
franchement à bord de fonctionnalités
hyper cool et sexy et ça je vous en
parle maintenant
avant toute chose on a reçu ça ce matin
on va regarder ce qu'il ya dans ce colis
je ne sais absolument pas ce que ça peu
être
et comme je suis curieux j'ai regardé
directement avec nous qu'est-ce qu'on a
là dedans à de nouveaux produits de
rhinau shield c'est quoi une nouvelle
coque c'est pour le p 20 on a de
nouvelles coques pour le web peuvent
invoquer cool et fera qu est ce que c
inpact protection de ce crime des
protections d'écran pour le web et 20
aussi cool merci rhino chine
donc on va parler aujourd'hui de la
gamme à de samsung qui va arriver
l'année prochaine
si vous avez suivi mes vidéos
précédentes on a déjà parlé ds 10 et s10
plus du capteur d'empreinte digitale
intégrée directement sous l'écran trip
module photo à la verticale il devrait
aussi avoir le samsung galaxy x avec son
écran pliable qui du coup pourrait
s'appeler le samsung galaxy fff pour
fold hebel pliable changement des
nominations d'ailleurs je sois si vous
avez vu ça pourrait être
huawei sorte un smartphone avec un écran
pliable avant samsung c'est un peu la
compétition pour début 2010 9 lequel des
deux sortira un smartphone avec un écran
pignal alors toute façon et moi je
fabriquais ont-ils série pour wei
pourrait fabriquer entre 20000 à 30000
exemplaires
samsung probablement un peu plus 49 51
ne sera pas énorme
de toute façon les prix vont être tout
de suite hyper élevé destiné à un marché
un petit peu niche et si ça prend si
derrière ça intéresse beaucoup de monde
ça pourrait être étendue au grand public
donc même si les smartphones à écran
pliable arrive début 2019
nous en tant que consommateur lambda on
devrait pas les avoir avant peut-être
2020-2021 voir un peu comment les
constructeurs vous reproduire cette
technologie dans les smartphones plutôt
grand public que les coûts baissent et
que ce soit intéressant
bon ça on va aussi de très près donc
vous invite à vous abonner comme ça dès
que j'ai les infos on peut les partager
ensemble
d'ailleurs il faut savoir que huawei
s'émancipe de ses fournisseurs samsung
display et lg pour les écrans oled pour
faire appel fabricant chinois bo
la fabrication de ces écrans oled et
l'ajustement des news sur la gamme
galaxy a qui va arriver en 2019 début
2018 vous emmener avec moi aux crs à las
vegas
on a pris en main en premier les samsung
galaxy à 8,8 plus
[Musique]
alors le a8 plus n'est pas disponible
dans tous les pays
en belgique en france notamment on les
trouve pas on trouve uniquement le
samsung galaxy à 8 ce qui est déjà pas
mal parce que le smartphone est quand
même plutôt cool il ya une info qui nous
vient du journal sud coréen qui
s'appelle investors investor nous dit
que c'est samsung galaxy a à neuf à dix
on connaît pas encore le nom début
d'année prochaine auront également un
capteur d'empreintes digitales
directement intégré à l'écran alors ce
ne sera pas le même capteur qu'on peut
retrouver sur le s10 sur l'ès 10 et
hésitent plus à dire trouver un capteur
à ultrasons fabriqués par qualcomm elle
l'art de retrouver un capteur intégré à
l'écran un peu plus tradi traduit je
sais pas s'il termine en tout cas le
même qu'on peut retrouver sur le vix von
hexe mais également un trip module photo
directement à graphique assassin compte
plus grand modèle
ça serait pour la gamme plus imaginer un
à neuf plus à 10 plus voilà alors après
la question que je me pose c'est comme
on n'a pas eu le à 8 plus nous en tout
cas dans l'hexagone
est-ce qu'on va retrouver ce
probablement potentiel à 9 plus avec ce
triplé module photo c'est pas sûr on
pourra probablement la voir en import
mais on n'aura pas forcément en vente
dans tous les pays après avoir comme
c'est quelque chose qui va vraiment été
nouveau est-ce-qu'il pour le cruiser
partout c'est pas impossible alors en
tout cas ces trois mois d'une faute au
moins être intéressant on n'aura pas
exactement les trois mêmes modules
photos que dans le s10 plus mais on
devrait avoir un premier appareil photo
en premier objectif un petit peu
classique un peu standard un deuxième
qui me permettra d'avoir un effet ben ok
donc de détacher l'arrière-plan et un
troisième objectif qui nous permettrait
d'avoir un super grand angle samsung qui
rêvent encore plus loin au niveau de la
photo et de la vidéo permettrait de le
rendre toujours plus accessible au plus
grand monde et ça s'est vraiment bien et
ce qui est très intéressant là dessus
c'est que on voit qu'au final c'est un
souk change pas brouiller les pistes
entre le haut de gamme et se disent à 10
plus le milieu de gamme probablement à
9,9 plus à disques à 10 plus ça reste à
voir
ça permet aux clients de son en milieu
de gamme de profiter de technologie
qu'on peut retrouver dans le haut de
gamme même s'ils sont pas exactement
mêmes technologies forcément réellement
palier entre les hauts de gamme et
milieu de gamme et plus en terme de coût
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose mais
ça peut être vraiment intéressant que ça
leur permet de se positionner par
rapport à la concurrence chinoise
toujours plus fort plus pressante
notamment à des marques comme xiaomi à
des marques comme huawei et sap en tout
c'est pas mal non plus
des nouveaux produits qui devraient être
présentées début 2019 au csa las vegas
dont je vous invite à vous abonner parce
que le csa les prochaines je veux aussi
aller faire un tour comme ça on pourra
voir prendre en mains ses produits
directement
[Musique]
vous invite aussi à la stabilité parce
que d'ici quelques jours on va aller à
l'ifab toutes les nouveautés il ya plein
de nouveautés qui vont arriver les
chemins pour ce gros salon était qu'on
peut trouver au mois de septembre
lifar durant quelques jours va y avoir
tous les meilleurs produits de la high
tech à découvrir
on va aller une conférence de presse de
au nord on va pas coûter de asus va
aussi y avoir des nouveautés on a pas
mal de choses allaient voir donc je vous
invite à rester connectés et bien
évidemment on ira faire aussi un tour au
mwc l'année prochaine à barcelone pour
voir toutes les nouveautés et les
tendances smartphones voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui dites nous ce que vous
en pensez
est ce que vous pourriez de tenter plus
par la gamme ssd
elles disent plus année prochaine ou
alors est-ce que cette gamme à 2019
pourrez vous tentez triple module photo
est ce que vous trouvez
s'intéressent-ils capteur d'empreintes
digitales sur l'écran est ce que pour
mousser poule faire un sens oui non
enfin vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire bien évidemment comme d'hab
vous invite à laisser des jolies pousse
à rester connectés à vous abonner merci
à vous merci beaucoup parce que en ce
moment les chiffres s'affolent on était
hier à plus de 450 nouveaux abonnés nous
rejoindre sur la chaîne la veille 430
donc là c'est juste génial merci a vous
d toujours plus nombreux et surtout
nombreux n'ai pas marqué tous vos
questions et suggestions interrogations
directement en touche aussi sur twitter
eyetv instagram tv qui va se développer
de plus en plus dont vous pouvez venir
le rejoindre également facebook et tous
les réseaux sociaux merci à vous et je
vous dis à très bientôt prenez soin de
vos [ __ ]
[Musique]